this morning on the dish a chef who
spent much of her life around the world
of food born in Seattle and Jamar comes
from a long line of food lovers and
restaurant wars her legendary aunt Ruby
Chow pioneered Chinese cuisine in
Seattle after training and working in
some of New York's top kitchens she
landed at the iconic West Village
restaurant the Beatrice end in 2016 she
bought the restaurant and made it her
own showcasing her love of live fire dry
aging techniques and over-the-top
presentations her visions has made it
one of the city's most coveted
reservations chef Angie Mar welcome to
the dish we don't have live fire but the
lovely table thank you so much for
having me tell us what's here so I
brought some things that are on the fall
menu as well as in the upcoming cookbook
so you've got a little 60-day dried
prime rib which we do only on Friday
nights
a little mutton stroganoff which is
actually one of my favorites from my
childhood some haricot vert a plum tart
and a bit of clafouti for dessert oh and
what is this little puppy most important
la Parisienne so a little bit of a
champagne cocktail I find it so
interesting that you started your career
in the real estate business how did you
make that transition because I'm sure
your parents are kind of like no sweetie
yeah
well you know my parents grew well my
father grew up in the restaurant
industry and you know he actually grew
up in that because of the Chinese
exclusionary Act so he actually didn't
have a choice except for to go into the
restaurant industry and you know I think
he worked hard and tirelessly all those
years and when I said that I was leaving
my career in the corporate world going
into the restaurant industry he was like
no what are you doing why did you make
that decision you know I am I had been
in the corporate world for about 12
years and I just wasn't I wasn't happy I
wanted to do something creative so going
back to that it was really exciting for
me
I love this great quote from you if I'm
going to cook I'm going to cook food
that takes you out at your knees yeah
Wow thank you yeah you know it's a it's
a philosophy that we definitely hold
true at the Beatrice because what we
always say is that you know everything
great starts around the dinner table
this is a restaurant that has like an
80-year history right but but when they
approached you and not always a great
history but right when they approached
you about being an executive chef
initially you were I didn't want it you
do you know I was working at a really
great restaurant at the time and it's
such a tumultuous history but I wasn't
really sure that I wanted to do that and
I haven't really made my name for myself
yet I was just kind of finding my way
and I called a very good friend of mine
Pat LaFrieda who is one of America's
biggest butchers yes we've profiled on
the show yeah he's fantastic and you
know I I called him and I said you know
look they want me to take this job and I
think it might be career suicide and he
said you know what it could be but it if
you turn it around it's gonna make your
career Wow Wow
so you not only did you turn it around
in three short years you went from being
head chef to head honcho own the
beatrice thinness yeah I bought it two
years ago
yeah I have doubts about buying it too I
did I went back to Pat LaFrieda Pat and
I really but what do I do it was like
should I hide for lottery numbers all
right I know what was his advice this
time you know what he told me was
everybody thought you were crazy from
for taking the job so if you buy it
you're just doubling down on crazy so
you might as well do it if you sign the
dish you could have this meal with
anyone pastor present I mean aside from
the three of you I think those are our
you know my father uh you know he was
such a huge inspiration for all the food
and really the ethos of the restaurant
itself and what it's become yeah chef
Angie Mar we so appreciate you being
with us here today
and for more on Angie Miranda - head to
our website at CBS this morning calm